aujourd'hui cette endémie elle a
démontré qu'on n'a pas de stratégie
vaccinale en france dire que la
stratégie vaccinale ça va de l'achat du
vaccin jusqu'à la vaccination de chacun
on n'y est pas on n'y est pas et on n'a
même pas un point dans l'horizon pour
démontrer face au gouvernement ne nous
donne même pas des éléments c'est ce que
vient de dire dominique seux tous les
peuples et les pays qui vont commencer à
s'en sortir qui s'en sortent y compris
que sa population c'est de donner des
échéances de donner des points à
l'occasion on n'y est pas aujourd'hui de
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est que
le gouvernement que le président de la
république nous disent est ce qu'il met
en place une stratégie vaccinale qui va
de l'achat de vaccins jusqu au vaccin
pour tous parce qu'on sera pas la
première pandémie et à la dernière
pandémie
donc il faut qu'on reconstruise cette
semaine je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
stratégie vaccinale sur lequel on a pas
de lisibilité
on a pas de lisibilité moi je vous le
dire dans le 7e arrondissement j'ai
ouvert un centre de vaccination
d'ailleurs la maire de paris sans aucun
soutien parce que leur la franchement on
les pains au lait pas là dessus moi j'ai
ouvert un centre de vaccination
grâce à la grèce qui aurait liens russo
qui nous fournit les doses l'appui de la
préfecture de police pour pouvoir
vacciner au maximum on vaccine au
maximum mais cette stratégie vaccinale
aujourd'hui les élus locaux chacun dans
notre coin on bricole on bricole
il faudrait plus de cohérence il
faudrait plus d'organisation il faudrait
démultiplier les centres de vaccination
y compris dans les entreprises dans les
quartiers d'affaires
il faut amener la vaccination très en
proximité et à voir les doses en
conséquence évidemment le nom le
confinement et l'arrêt de l'école ça a
provoqué des dégâts
je vous dire et je pèse mes mots
irréversibles sur des enfants décrochage
scolaire décrochage psychologiques pour
ne pas dire psychiatrique les femmes
seules avec des enfants
tout ça a été mis à terre on a des
impacts et des dégâts psychologiques et
psychiatriques dont va payer très cher
les effets avant sept ans